internet les ados sont accros 96% des 11
18 ans surfer régulièrement sur la toile
ils sont fans des forums de discussion
des blogs mais la majorité l'utilisent
aussi pour leur travail scolaire
c'est ce que révèle une enquête de
médiamétrie qui montre également que les
enfants encouragent leurs parents à se
connecter
yann fossurier loitzl moigne pour
michael 14 ans cliquer sur une souris
est devenu un geste banal l'internet
il utilise quasiment tous les jours ce
qu'il préfère lui ce sont les tchats ces
groupes de discussions qui permettent de
retrouver les copains le soir en
rentrant du collège et c'est bien quand
même on peut en discuter le temps tous
mes amis on a en trop quoi faire comme
devoir en cours on peut les rechercher
des documents chez voilà quoi est-ce que
tu arrives à internet simplifié le petit
frère de michel raphaël élus et si un
utilisateur assidu de l'internet
il s'en sert notamment pour ses devoirs
petit exemple avec cette recherche
d'image sur les dieux égyptiens pour son
cours d'histoire
la scea tard c'est l'écho chercher et je
fais c'est souvent belge fait ça quand
la trouve trop bobo augmentation aller à
un concert
selon une enquête de médiamétrie 75% des
11 18 ans utilisent internet pour leurs
devoirs les parents bien entendu sont
ravis mais reste vigilant sur l'usagé
que leurs enfants font de cet outil
déjà nous en tant qu'adjoint penseront
pas bien compte du temps qu'on passe là
dessus ça défile vraiment et je suis
très vigilant là dessus mais j'essaye de
canaliser qui passe pas des journées
entières sur voilà
mais les parents commencent eux aussi à
se convertir à internet sous influence
des plus jeunes
selon médiamétrie les foyers avec
enfants de moins de 15 ans sont les
mieux équipées en informatique au total
aujourd'hui en france huit millions de
foyers sont connectés à internet
finn